some of the strangest things that I
encountered are because the doctors
themselves aren't asking questions for
instance one young man was referred to
me by a dermatologist because they had
these horrible sores all over his penis
and no one knew the origin of this and
it caused him to withdraw socially and
he was afraid to engage in any sexual
experiences with a partner at least as
the dermatologist and his primary care
physician understood it I took a sexual
history and one of the questions I
always ask as tell me about your last
sexual experience and I also asked about
the last time you masturbated yourself
and what technique to use when you
masturbate this poor man who was so
anxious at work would a lock his door
and Rob himself against this industrial
carpeting on his office floor and
severely burned and abrade his penis
which he didn't notice because it was
aroused until after he had ejaculated
he'd find these sores and then of course
they were very tempting you know tender
and he was humiliated at the thought of
telling anyone about this yet he went to
the dermatologist and his primary care
physician in the hope of finding relief
some kind of medication that would take
away these burns or at least alleviate
the pain that he's experiencing and yet
he had a problem with compulsive
masturbation in part he found that was a
relief for the high anxiety he
experienced at work so this was a
multi-dimensional problem and we were
able to fix this by helping him learn
better skills to cope at work develop an
alternative pattern of masturbation
limit the frequency of masturbation and
eventually get him dating having sexual
experiences with other partners he's not
married and has two kids and he limits
his sexual experiences primarily to
those with his wife with some occasional
masturbation using a technique most
people would find more conventional